hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 5 of the City of God Augustine
of Hippo engages in a long and somewhat
complex discussion about the
compatibility between two seemingly
incompatible doctrines one of these is
the freedom of the human will or freedom
of choice
and the other is what we call divine
foreknowledge the idea that God would
know everything that is going to happen
from eternity or from the inception of
things and this was not a problem that
came up uniquely for Christian
philosophers and theologians as we see
it had already been discussed quite a
bit by ancient Greek and Roman
philosophers long before Christianity
came on the scene because it was felt to
be quite an issue and there are a range
of different ideas or doctrines on this
this convoluted question so the the core
issue here is you know if God exists and
God does have foreknowledge of
everything that is going to happen that
means God knows in advance is freedom of
will actually possible freedom of the
human will because it seems that if God
knows everything knows future
contingents as they're called or the
things that are going to happen if
they're if God has sort of a
propositional knowledge that I will at
this point walk across the room and
address you with these very words then
it seems like I don't actually have a
choice in it I have to do it it happens
behind us S&E and you can take God out
of the picture if you like you can
substitute some sort of mechanistic
picture of the universe or you know any
other way of having something that we
could call fate or necessity ruling if
that's the case then it seems that we
don't have free will
and Augustine is going to place himself
here in conversation with Cicero a
earlier non-christian Roman philosopher
and statesman Cicero wrote a book called
on fate in which he discussed this very
problem he also discusses it to some
degree in on the nature of the gods and
on divination and Cicero opposed himself
to the Stoics on this matter the Stoics
were a school of philosophy that among
other things held that there is a God
which they called Zeus and understood as
this divine logos permeating everything
they thought that Zeus was fully
rational and also had a sort of
providential care for every single thing
within the universe so everything is set
up structured in certain ways and they
also held that everything is connected
together in some sort of causal Nexus so
the Stoics were willing to say that
there could be divine foreknowledge
that's why they thought there was
divination and Cicero is going to attack
them on this now the Stoics of course
didn't go all the way to saying
everything is totally necessitated they
said some things are not up to necessity
they are up to us but the kind of causes
that we are also within this vast causal
Nexus and it's you know you can
interpret their position in various ways
but one way of interpreting is we don't
really have free will and so Augustine
is having Cicero engaged with the Stoics
you know and say listen because there is
divine foreknowledge everything is fated
which means that we don't actually have
freewill we can either go along you know
kicking and screaming but we'll still
have to go along or we can agree to it
and follow along with it that much is at
least up to us Augustine takes Cicero as
developing a different alternate
position on this Cicero wanted to say
that there is no knowledge
of future events so there's no
foreknowledge either on the part of
human beings or on the part of God and
what this would mean is that we would in
fact have freedom of the will so Cicero
is denying one thing in order to keep
another thing which he sees is
incompatible Augustine says Cicero
doesn't really see that the consequence
of this is that he's essentially in the
same position as the fool in Psalms who
says there is no God the fool says in
his heart there is no God because to
deny foreknowledge is to deny that God
is in fact God a point that we'll come
back to momentarily so this is felt to
be a central problem on the part of
Augustine and Cicero is in effect
putting us in a dilemma he says he says
if the knowledge of future things is
granted there follows a chain of
consequences which ends in this there
can be nothing depending on our own free
wills if there is anything depending on
our wills we must go backwards by the
same step of reasoning till we arrive at
the conclusion there is no foreknowledge
how do we do this we go backward through
this if there is free will all things do
not happen according to fate if all
things do not happen according to fate
there is not a certain order of causes
if there is not a certain order of
causes neither is there a certain order
of things for known by God and if there
is no fixed in certain order of causes
for known by God all things cannot be
said to happen as he foreknew they would
happen and so there you know there is no
foreknowledge of future events in God so
we're placed in a dilemma here
according to Augustine by Cicero where
we either have to choose one or the
other and it's a dilemma because we
don't want to choose either one of these
because if we say well there is no
causal Nexus it looks like everything is
kind of random or arbitrary but if we
don't do that then there's no human free
will and
and that's not only a troubling
conclusion for us that has all sorts of
other moral implications like well if
somebody does the wrong thing are we
right in punishing them or should we
just say well no free will so what is
the solution to this Augustine says for
the religious mind there is a solution
it's a both/and rather than either/or
and he says that you can believe this by
faith that there is divine foreknowledge
and there is free choice of the will
that's an option but Augustine doesn't
want to just stop with saying God's
mysterious ways or something like that
he wants to have a rational explanation
of this because he is not just a
Christian believer but a Christian
philosopher and he's trying to engage
with the ways in which previous previous
philosophers have made sense of this in
the past so how does he do this he his
argument runs along these lines or you
might say his rational explanation so
one central aspect of this is realizing
that wills are in fact causes of actions
so they're part of whatever order of
causality we've got going on as a matter
of fact they're included in the order
that would be grasped by divine
foreknowledge that is God in seeing us
you know ahead of time and we'll get to
the head of time in a little bit
doing the things that we do because we
willingly choose to do them sees us
willing that and that willing is not
something that's determined by God
seeing it ahead of time God sees it
ahead of time because we do in fact
we'll to do that very thing so we become
free causes you might say within this
causal nexus he says it does not follow
that though for God a certain order
there is a certain order of all causes
there must be nothing depending on the
free
exercise of our own wills our own wills
are included in that which is embraced
by his foreknowledge human wills are
causes of human action he who were for
knew all the causes of things with
certainly among those causes not have
been ignorant of our wills so when I
choose to cross the room willingly
because I could have stayed back here
God knew that I would choose to do this
in order to demonstrate something to you
that's how the line of reasoning goes
here he also says that the you know
Cicero and Stoics are kind of playing
around with ideas in a way that doesn't
get them what they want but a way that
helps us understand things he says
everything does happen by causes and the
Stoics and Cicero were you know sort of
trying to classify the different types
of causes that would be involved one of
them is the material cause and Augustine
actually rules that Isis the material
causes don't actually determine anything
they're more determined than anything
else they're more made rather than
making but we can talk about natural
causes the sort of order of the universe
itself and all the causal mechanisms and
we can talk about voluntary causes and
fortuitous causes fortuitous causes
would be those that we don't really
understand they seem to be sort of
chance and an Augustine says listen you
can either look at them as not really
being causes or you can say if they are
causes they essentially can be rolled
into the natural causes and he says
natural causes are actually determined
in one way or another by God whether
directly or indirectly through some sort
of causal chain but then there's also
voluntary causes which are due to
particular Wills those would include the
will of God but also the Wills of other
created spirits as he calls them the
good angels and bad angels but putting
that aside there is also the voluntary
choices of other human beings including
ourselves so you can say well you know
the environment that I
grew up in determined me to act and
think and you know behave in certain
ways that entire environment that you're
talking about is the product not just of
natural causes but of a whole ton of
voluntary causes you know the street
went this way they decided not to put a
bus line yeah you know this area is in
poverty because all the businesses
pulled out those are voluntary causes
within this way of looking at things the
other thing that he says that's
particularly interesting here going back
to this issue of the sisterhood raised
is if God were in fact not actually
prescient if he did not have
foreknowledge then God would not
actually be God God would be something
lesser than whatever it is that we
understand to be God so if we what he's
saying here is if we take foreknowledge
away from God let's not even call that
God anymore so we have to have free
causes and we also have to have a God
that can see everything from the very
beginning that is knowledgeable or
conscious of what it is that we will
before we even do will it he also has
this very interesting discussion that
helps flesh out this entire doctrine
about wills being when our wills wills
he says are not subject to necessity at
least in certain manners now one example
of a matter that we don't choose we're
all going to die something right unless
there's some sort of amazing life
extension technology that you know we
see in science fiction novels or or
fantasy stories but in general we're all
going to die and and you know you can I
suppose you can die willingly or
unwillingly in certain respects but
ultimately it is on it doesn't matter
whether you will it or not you will die
but when it comes to the whole you know
large variety the host of our actions
throughout life putting on
this tie instead of another tie not
wearing a tie at all shooting this video
or not that is up to us our choices are
motivational factors our deliberations
can definitely be given parameters given
orientations and directions by all sorts
of things but ultimately according to
Augustine we do choose we engage in
actions as he says you know because our
wills exist as wills we do what it is
that we will all other things being
equal and we don't do the things that we
don't will so you know he says here that
we do whatever we do by willing and what
would not be done if we were unwilling
so we can think of many examples of this
in our life and you can say oh well
you're just rationalizing that after the
fact there's no you know one thing you
can point out that is freewill inside a
brain scan or something like that
Augustine that's fine that's cracking
about that sort of thing just think
about your own conscious perceptions do
you actually will things freely at some
point in time oh it doesn't take every
single decision being free all it
requires is that at least some are and
then he says we can also suffer things
unwillingly right we can have things
imposed upon us I don't like for example
getting old and you know my my beard
turning white and and my mustache still
being brown but now getting white as
well while my hair is mostly brownish
red because I think it looks kind of
silly right I'm suffering that
unwillingly as well go get yourself hair
dye that's a choice I could make right
but then I don't choose exactly how the
dye works and stuff like that and I
don't choose whether I'd have to pay for
it there's all sorts of things that we
don't actually choose but are imposed
upon us but those are imposed
precisely because there is some other
will that is determining things he says
a stronger will it could be understood
as the will of God setting up the
natural order so that you know this is
the way bodies age right given the
genetics that I have or or it could be
voluntary things I have to pay if I want
to go get hair dye to indulge a kind of
vanity all of that is determined by
somebody making a voluntary choice so
you don't get away from will that way
and the conclusion is you know that God
knows there is something in our will he
says we're not by no means compelled
retaining the precedence of God to take
away the freedom of the will or
retaining the freedom of the will to
deny that he is prescient of future
things we embrace both and what you're
seeing here is Augustine providing a
philosophical account or justification
for something that Christians believe by
faith but he's trying to provide an
account that could hold up even for
non-believers and address somebody like
say Cicero so in Augustine's view there
is no inherent incompatibility between
the precedence of God or whatever else
you want to substitute in its place and
human free will
you